[Music]
this morning on the dish we take you to
south africa where a remarkable young
chef is making his mark in cape town at
the city's tarly restaurant natco
creates a collection of intricate dishes
that draw on the region's strong indian
influence bakitiko's work is also his
connection with the neighborhood he grew
up in deborah potter went to meet him
nateco's acclaimed culinary skills are
on display at cape town's upmarket tully
restaurant where he is head chef
but today he swapped his expansive
kitchen
for his mother rochelle's small home on
the outskirts of the city center
they've been up since the crack of dawn
cooking for their community i might be
able to go home in the evening and have
a good plate of food where someone else
goes home and
there's nothing for them to eat
it was here on the dusty flatlands of
mitchell's plain an area plagued by
unemployment and gangsterism that he
grew up
and it was here his love for sharing
food was born watching his mother who
didn't have much herself ran a weekly
soup kitchen young nate often by her
side
so when i start cooking it's like i
i extract myself from everything and
everyone around me all negativity and
adjusting positive to go forward and
putting a beautiful dish on the table
years later on his days off he's still
preparing meals that help keep hunger at
bay today's is a simple chicken biryani
but co sacrifices none of the excellence
that has made tully famous the very few
realized that it was coming from a
brilliant head chef it's just nate down
the road making us some briyani right
yeah they know i'm a chef but they don't
know i'm a head chef of a beautiful
restaurant like tali
this being tully
a modern indian eatery with a south
african twist in the heart of cape town
it's owned by international
restauranteer liam tomlin
not everybody
agrees with the way we do it there's
some real traditional
indian lovers who think
this isn't what it should be but the
food is clever here nate does an amazing
job and i've worked with thousands and
thousands of young chefs over the years
and there are there's always the
standout ones and nate's one of those
standout ones can you just do this i get
to experience that first hand in the
tully kitchen where chef ko was teaching
me the ropes my garlic slicing skills
leave much to be desired
and while the chopping might have been
slow it doesn't detract from the taste
we've been seasoning from the beginning
the work is not glamorous but each dish
is lovingly prepared so basically thali
means a big dish with a lot of small
dishes on top of it it's basically our
take on indian food
and i don't think people realize how
important indian culture is in south
africa there's huge indian influence yes
there is a lot of flavors and components
that goes hand in hand together
the result a magnificent feast i'm ready
to taste it so this is ostrich carpaccio
with
so it's a spicy apple puree then we've
got some pickled mushrooms there and
then the sour onion beware there should
be a kitty as well
it is absolutely insane
another firm favorite is the pickled
fish co uses the very south african king
clip soaked in lime juice and spices
overnight
but one of tali's most popular dishes is
the humble spinach leaf transformed
under koh's expert hands into something
far more sublime yes
it says
in a temporary batter which we make
ourselves
that's one of my favorites this is
amazing i'm eating a spinach leaf who
could possibly imagine that a spinach
leaf can taste this good
cooking has always been coe's happy
place his father took early retirement
to pay for chef school every day he
would make a two-hour journey across
cape town to get there
what's it like traversing the two worlds
you live in you live in mitchell's plane
where there's poverty
gangsterism drug abuse you come here
it's a fine dining experience in many
ways i wouldn't say it's difficult but
it is challenging you keep going back to
your roots
i believe that you shouldn't forget
where you come from because that's where
it all started
even the guys that went the wrong route
they are part of my journey
becoming who i am
it's a journey that clearly remains with
ko who's become a top chef with an
unassuming manner still striving to
bring joy with his culinary creations no
matter who he prepares a meal for
for cbs saturday morning debra patter
cape town
amazing i want that spinach i was just
going to say a spinach leaf that's never
tasted like this a brilliant profile on
a young chef who seems to be doing
amazing work and i want the food back on
arts we're gonna have to work on those
for a little ostrich
yeah you went haywire over that one it
was i mean it looked good yeah we like
good food we do like good food we like
to eat it we like lots of things around
here